Kourtney Kardashian is ready to dish out
some tough love to Scott Disick I'm over
it
[Music]
in a sneak peak at the next Keeping Up
with the Kardashians tension comes to a
head between the mom of three and her ex
I don't want the kids just seem like a
tough love from wild partying to being
photographed with a slew of different
women the 34 year old reality stars
behavior has landed him in the headlines
a lot this year I have to handle it when
he's out photographed you know yeah a
different hooker every day and it looks
like Court is over it Scott has been
linked to a number of young starlets
over the last few months including Bella
Thorne we're chilling my friends were
cool and most recently Sophia Richie
there's just too much going on on
Saturday Scott was spotted holding hands
with a 19 year old model at LAX Airport
before catching a flight to Milan this
is a serious Sofia later took to
Instagram stories to document their
romantic Italian vacation it was never a
down moment
meanwhile Kourtney stepped out in San
Francisco on Friday night looking hotter
than ever with her sisters Kim and Khloe
in tow never known Kourtney to be the
skiddy ever in my life and on Saturday
the 38 year old was seen enjoying a date
night with her boyfriend model units
Benjamin a great restaurant Taverna Tony
in Malibu
[Music]
you